hello and welcome to another mathematics
and stock indicators tutorial within
python next few videos are going to be
discussing this term right here
uh arun in the indicator it was
developed by
tushar shande back in the mid 90s and
arun is sanskrit
for literally meaning dawn's early light
so if that doesn't give you an idea what
a rune is here we go
it's going to determine whether or not a
stock is trending and then that trend
strength
if it is and the calculation for a rune
is pretty simple and this is one of the
more simple indicators
that we're going to even be covering and
so to calculate it
it's going to be there's going to be two
lines here and you're going to have the
arun upline and the
roon downline the rune up line is going
to be time frame minus how long since
the last high
divided by that time frame times 100 so
it's kind of like a percentage of how
long
um and that percentage is going to be of
whatever time frame you choose so
you can choose anything you choose a 5
you can choose
a 10 day or something like that but the
idea here is
how long has it been since the last uh
high price right the last highest price
so
um i wouldn't necessarily recommend you
use something as short as like a five
it's probably better to use like a 15 to
20 something plus
um and then the down is basically the
exact same thing only it's just for how
long since the last
low so with this indicator you could
actually
forget about dividing by the time frame
times 100 for the percentage thing you
could just leave it
and the indicator will look exactly the
same but this is just kind of a way to
normalize it
if you wanted to compare it to maybe you
wanted to compare it to another chart
and still display the arun line
so yeah you can just keep that in mind
now finally
that's pretty much it now i'm going to
show you guys a few examples including
you know what we're going to be doing
with this
um so let me bring up the charting
application here
and uh so now uh we'll just pick
something we'll do uh we'll do apple
first and here it is
and we just drag it over here and fit it
okay so here's an apple and down here is
our room we're using a 20 time period so
it's 20 days
um although it's probably a little bit
more than that so our time frame or
the stock here is 10 years so it's
probably actually more like 60 days but
anyway um so as you can see the idea
here we've got you know the arun upline
is this green line
the room down line is this red line so
every time you know this trend starts
trending up i mean this thing the arun
called it instantly here right
as that new high was uh announced and
then it keeps hitting new highs so it
continues trending up
and then you can almost see here where
it kind of pops down a little bit there
and so the room down is kind of coming
up but we're still you know we still
have no crossover
still had no crossover we didn't even
have a crossover until this point here
which you know is right here and it did
trend down sure enough
and then it crossed back over again here
and didn't cross over again until
really here and then it continued going
up and then we finally had you know nice
strong
downward and sure enough it did go down
so
honestly for the simplicity of this
indicator um
i was pretty surprised i've never
actually used the iron indicator before
i decided i was going to do tutorial
video on it
and uh pretty interesting indicators say
the least you don't really hear too much
about this one or at least i didn't
but maybe that's just apple right so
let's go ahead and let's look at a
couple other ones so we'll do
let's do ebay ebay has done a lot of
fluctuating
at least recently
it's all year to date ebates you can see
how ebay has been doing this year
so again you can see here uh where we've
got a definite uptrend here
sure enough it calls it at about here
and then says
you know hey you might want to leave
right about here um
and then again it says you might want to
leave right about here and sure enough
you should have left
uh did signal you here but then told you
never mind
um really a little bit after so like
here
um anyway downtrend here uptrend there
sure enough i mean it's calling these
trends
pretty well which again i'm just pretty
surprised i didn't have too much faith
in this indicator when i was looking at
how you calculate it
um i should have let me go back here
do this hopefully
yeah so like if you were looking at a
shorter time frame this is an example
where you know you might want
uh like this would be just under year to
date and we're using each
little thing is about three days so to
give you an idea here let's
uh plot let me plot up a one year of
ebay we'll keep 20 and see how that
looks so let me close out of this and
edit the
time frame here for us so here is
uh still in a room 20 only we're
considering one year's data
so it's every day right and so as you
can see here with a highly
volatile stock you're kind of getting
late signals right so you're getting
signaled that it's an uptrend
here and you're getting signaled that
never mind here
and then you're getting signal up trend
again here at the peak
of this stock and so on so again i'd
like to use ebay because ebay is
like one of the most volatile like up
down up down up down up down stocks like
this year to date
uh at least that everybody knows about
and so
that's a good example whereas you can
compare this to maybe a company like
tesla who's just
only recently started coming down but
for the most part was just an uptrend
the whole way
um it was actually quite accurate so for
for
i would say you know long-term investing
uh this is actually a pretty decent
pretty decent indicator right um
because here in this scenario with a
nice level
non-highly volatile stock you can see
here that
indeed it it would have made you money
to trade it with tesla but of course
tesla was going up the whole time but
you can see where tesla's going down
here and if you were
warned of that you know really right
here which is quite a good warning
because you know the crossover the
moving average was pretty late as well
so
um for later than this
anyway uh that's that with uh this
this rune indicator in the next video
what we're going to be talking about is
actually programming this rune indicator
into python
and then after that we're going to
actually uh graph it up just like this
so you guys can play with it yourself
and see what you think
so anyway stay tuned for the next video
as always thanks for watching thanks for
the support of the subscriptions
and until next time